so basically my research project
explores the relationship between
Victorian choreography which is the art
of flower giving and biology and the way
I did that was by constructing Victorian
dresses from real flowers and pairing it
with biological images of that same
flower and basically my research cold
from Victorian fashion to Victorian
communication design as well as
choreographer which all played huge
rolls in my project and it was both
creative and I and academic in the way
that I spent half my time in the studio
and then I spent the other portion of my
time in the lab everything the mines
I'll have about 10 printed pieces and
then I'll have my book on display for
people to read it's hardcover 134 pages
it's entitled for feminist sukkah and
yeah I'm excited to to be able to
present my project chocolate people why
project and also for people to see it in
book form to be able to turn pages and
read a little bit about what I learned
probably the most important thing that
I've learned about this process is that
definitely when you're doing intensive
research you need time and you need
support from other people to do it which
is why I really appreciated the RA
office at Carnegie Mellon because they
gave me a year to be able to complete
this grant which I think I use all the
time they gave me to complete it and I
definitely learned how to manage time a
lot better too I think after the meeting
of the minds I'm definitely going to
continue to develop this technique and
continue to do things of this nature
maybe even explore it as a potential
thing to explore more in graduate school
or other grants
I think that I've started to unravel
something but I haven't completely
unraveled it so I'd love to gain more
exposure in this specific topic